So that's a lovely photograph.
Obviously that's the establishment of a new center.
And then the center can be a cathedral to and often is of course in classic
towns,
European towns in particular,
although it's not only European towns that are like this there,
there's a center that's made out of stone.
So that would be the cathedral and it's got the highest tower on top of the
tower.
There's often a cross and that's the symbolic center.
So people are,
are drawn together around whatever the cross represents.
Now that the cross obviously represents a center cause it's an x,
right?
X marks the spot.
So the center of the Cross is the center.
And then the cathedrals often in a cross shape,
which also marks the center.
And then in the cathedral there's a dome often and that's the sky.
And that's that ladder that reaches from Earth to heaven.
So it's a recapitulation of the same idea.
So,
and people are drawn to that center and the center is the symbol of what unites
them.
And what unites them is the faith that the cathedral is the embodiment of.
And you think,
well,
what does the faith mean?
And again,
we're approaching this psychologically and what it means is that we,
everyone who's a member of that group accepts the transcendent ideal of the
group.
Now the thing is,
if you're the member of a group,
you accept the transcendent ideal of the group.
That's what it means to be a member of a group.
So if you're in a work team and you're all working on a project,
what you've essentially done is decided that you're going to make the goal
unquestionable,
right?
I mean,
you might argue about the details,
but if you're tasked with something,
you know,
here's a job for you.
10 people organize yourself around the job,
you can argue about how you're going to do the job,
but you can't argue about the job,
then the group falls apart.
And so there's an act of faith in some sense,
the reason that the act of faith is necessary is because it's very,
very difficult to specify without error what that central aim should be,
given that there's any number of aims,
right?
And it's a very,
very difficult thing to figure out.
And this is something we're going to do a little bit tonight is like what should
the aim be around which a group would congregate?
You know,
so,
so Matt,
especially if it's a large group and it's a large group that has to stay
together across very large swaths of time and the group is an incredibly
diverse,
you know,
what possible kind of ideal could unite a large group of diverse people across a
very large stretch of time.
That's a really,
really hard question.
And I think part of the way that question has been answered is it's been
answered symbolically and in images because it's so damn complicated that it's
almost impossible to articulate so,
but obviously you need to a center around which everyone can unite because if
you don't,
then everyone is at odds with one another.
Like if I don't know what you're up to and you don't know what he's up to,
we have no were just strangers and we don't know that our ethics match at all.
Then the probability that we're going to be able to exist harmoniously decreases
rapidly to zero.